in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Aaron
and Nicole are with us hi how are you
welcome welcome where do you guys live
Dallas Texas fun well welcome to
Nashville and here to do a debt-free
scream yeah very fun how much have you
paid off seventy five thousand and
thirty five months why did it go
very well done making what kind of money
well we started off about seventy five
and ended up hopefully this year about
115 Wow nice raise what happened to your
incomes I got a promotion and we've just
been working our butts off lots of extra
jobs yeah okay so you paid off about a
little over $2,000 a month average for
about three years what kind of debt was
this well was everything we were just
normal we had a credit card two vehicles
a student loan but the biggest chunk was
thirty six thousand when we bought our
house in 2007 and we financed it a
hundred percent
we took it at eighty twenty in which I
know you love those HELOC it was 20 year
term for eight point three four percent
she got rid of the second mortgage in
this mob yes very well done okay
very cool so what happened three years
ago that puts you on this journey tell
me the story
well back in 2008 I was getting out of
the military and one of the finest human
beings alive
named John Stroud kind of took me under
his wings as a mentor and you know we're
come back from a hunting trip one time
and he was talking about how he did Dave
Ramsey's I never heard of you before
and this is one of the most successful
guys I've ever met just living give like
no one we never met before so you know
that's stuck in my head in a few weeks
later we had a presentation on FPU at
church and we thought well this is I
think somebody's trying to tell and John
and Susan actually said well hey guys
when y'all finish this up you know we'll
pay for your trip out the Nashville the
deer screams your mentor paid for you to
come yes sir
that is very neat that's fun so you went
through Financial Peace University well
that's funny when they offered it at our
church
didn't even have 100 bucks to take the
class so we borrowed the CDs and she
would listen to one then I would listen
to it just on our commutes we eventually
and facilitating coordinated for our
church and well coordinated again in
January so thank you very much we
appreciate that okay so what when you
were going through the CDs what was the
thing that caught you off guard I guess
the first time you got the information
into your brain and you went that's
going to be harder or that's going to be
easier or something than you thought
something that was completely different
than you thought before you started
getting in the information Cash Money I
talked about that yeah cash has been
absolutely I think the cornerstone of
this whole process because even if
you're terrible at budgeting once you
quit borrowing and start living on cash
you have an automatic budget and that's
true okay that's good so that was
probably the yeah I guess fortunately
cash and get on a written budget I think
for me I had been the one trying to do
our money and you know I had a budget
per se and I budget for groceries and
budgeted for gas but it was just all
those incidentals those other envelopes
and other budget areas that are not
emergencies or surprises like you say
that I just had never taken into account
so you know you'd need new tires and
that goes on the credit card or
Christmas rolls around and that goes on
the credit card so it finally had us
like you said looking out the the
windshield inside the rearview mirror
yeah I got you
so take us back to 36 months ago and you
sat down and you did the first yes and I
think I got it from the from the the
table maybe six or seven times we had to
reconvene a couple times it was rough
wait so you're fighting well I was
freaking out oh oh you just have a no
okay well I grew up the solution to
everything my dad always told me was
just go make more money yeah that's what
I would turn to soon as there was a
money problem I gotta go make more money
give me more money
wait I'm trying to drill in Lee doesn't
matter how much money we make you know
we can still be in debt we don't no
matter how little we make we can still
get out of that so he would get up and
circle around and circle around come
back down sit back down and okay alright
they just I mean when we got married and
finally combined our fine
his money freaked me out so much I gave
her about a halfway full fifty gallon
trash bag full of unopened bills like
hey tell your boy conflict is money you
just never yeah all right so you sat
down and you did that you freaked out
when you saw the nose and now here you
stand three years later three long years
later was it easier or harder now
looking back on it then you thought it
was gonna be that night easier Oh ways
here really yeah way easier that in the
beginning it was tough just it seemed
insurmountable
once I saw actual attraction happening
and I realized hey this is doable and we
had a month and I mean I can shoot for
that mm-hmm so that was I was a big deal
for me just knowing that don't have a
plan yes and the harder we work the
faster it's gonna go so once you got one
month down you're like okay and then you
do too much yeah maybe we're not do
forces we can do I felt like you know
maybe I'm not a complete income in
nincompoop you know maybe I really cuz
you build confidence don't you yes as
you go you know what was the hardest
part of the journey for you all I think
you know you talked about I think your
role is if you can't get debt-free in 18
to 24 months sell it and so looking back
we should have probably sold our
vehicles and gone down in vehicle
because I think we got to that two-year
mark and that's that's when we start
coordinating at for you because we
needed an extra push to get us to the
end because we got to that two-year mark
and repin see we had that last big HELOC
left and we're going oh my gosh we're
never going to get there
we've been going so long and so hard
we're never going to get there but it as
always it went faster than we
anticipated so that last big debt at the
bottom of the debt snowball even with
the emotional head of steam you've got
it still stops you in your tracks they
still lead you I'm overwhelmed again yes
well but it's fun to pay off those
little guys as they go but when you see
when you're done you've already put
tears in and they're still I think it
was twenty twenty-five thousand left
we're going oh but it's taken us two
years to get 20 how are we going to get
whatever the mad Dave I will say any
sense you always say that a you know
whenever you really start following
to plan he starts blessing you mm-hmm
it's been absolutely tremendous the
amount of blessings we've had since
we've actually started managing our
money like you know we're supposed to
our careers financially and when your
income almost up crazy opportunities do
anything from everywhere it's just been
unbelievable have we been blessed hmm
that's very cool and so how long have
you all been married almost ten years
okay
she had seven years of regular of normal
and three years on this and now you're
free how's it feel I'm relieved amazing
so the 10-year mark is coming up but now
you don't have any debt awesome Wow very
funny and who's your young son tell us
what his name
this is cold and all this cold three and
a half and we have another one at home
Oh perfect very fun okay
well excellent job you guys it's a great
story your your success you did it
so proud of you congratulations and
thank you for leading the class all
right Erin and Nicole and Cole $75,000
paid off in 35 months making 75 now
making 115 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
oh I love it well done well done and
that's excellent that is so fun